FIRST, DEMS GET AWAY FROM
GOVERNING.
THAT'S THE FOCUS ON TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT REMAINED IN
WASHINGTON OVER THE WEEKEND,
VERY SNOWY, READY AND WILLING TO
DO WITH DEAL WITH THE DEMOCRATS
TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT,
NANCY PELOSI AND HER CREW LEFT
TOWN.
BUT THEY TALK A GOOD GAME.
>> WHY PUNISH PEOPLE WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR FOOD STAMPS BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT IS HAVING A TEMPER
TANTRUM?
OPEN GOVERNMENT FIRST.
I HOPE HE DOES THE RIGHT THING.
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
MORE OR TO SECURITY?
LET'S HAVE EDITED BUT WHILE WE
WERE HAVING THE DEBATE, LET'S
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
>> OPEN UP THIS GOVERNMENT
TOMORROW.
>> Laura: AS THEY ALWAYS SAY,
FORGET AT WHAT THEY SAY, LOOK
AT WHAT THEY DO.
AS THEY ADJOURNED THE HOUSE ON
FRIDAY, MORE THAN 30 DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
NEEDED TO CATCH A CHARTERED
FLIGHT BOUND FOR THE SUNNY
SHORES OF PUERTO RICO.
WHILE 800,000 GOVERNMENT WORKERS
REMAIN ON FURLOUGH, THESE VERY
CONCERNED DEMOCRATS WERE LIVING
THE HIGH LIFE AT A BEACH RESORT
IN SAN JUAN.
VERY NICE.
THE TRIP CAME COURTESY OF 109
LOBBYISTS FROM FACEBOOK, AMAZON,
VARIOUS UNIONS, AND MICROSOFT.
YOU KNOW, THE LITTLE PEOPLE.
IT WAS PART OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
HISPANIC CAUCUS' BOLD PACKED
RETREAT.
THE DEMOCRATS WHERE REPORTEDLY
THERE TO SURVEY THE DAMAGE OF
HURRICANE MARIA AND TALK WITH
VARIOUS UNION GROUPS.
REMEMBER THAT TIDBIT.
HERE IS SENATOR ROBERT MENENDEZ.
HE'S TAKING A VERY PERSONAL
INTEREST IN THE LOCAL RECOVERY
EFFORTS.
LET'S
DOMINIC LOOKS LIKE INSTEAD OF
HELPING HURRICANE VICTIMS, HE'SH
HELPING HURRICANE VICTIMS, HE'SL
HELPING HURRICANE VICTIMS, HE'SI
HELPING HURRICANE VICTIMS, HE'SG
HIMSELF TO A HURRICANE ON THE
ROCKS.
MM.
THIS IS A LIBERAL PACKED JUNKET
PAID FOR BY LOBBYISTS SO THAT
CONGRESSMEN AND SENATORS CAN
FROLIC IN THE TROPICS WITH
CELEBRITIES.
YES, THE BIG CONGRESSIONAL
GETAWAY ON THE SAME WEEKEND,
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW, AS BROADWAY
MEGASTAR LYNN MANUAL MIRANDA
IS BRINGING HIS 20 AWARD-WINNING
MUSICAL "HAMILTON" WITH THE
ORIGINAL CAST, NO LESS.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN TRIPPING OVER
THEMSELVES PRAISING MIRANDA FOR
HIS TIRELESS EFFORTS TO BRING
"HAMILTON" TO PUERTO RICO TO
SUPPORT THE ARTS ON THE ISLAND.
A NICE THING.
THE PLAN WAS TO PERFORM THE
MUSICAL FOR THREE WEEKS.
A MASS SUCCESS.
AT THE THEATER AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF PUERTO RICO.
NOW, THERE IS A REALLY
INTERESTING BACK STORY THAT GOT
LOST IN ALL THE GLOSSY COVERAGE
BUT IT'S THE ALMA MATER OF LIN
MANUEL'S FATHER.
THEY RAISED A MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE THEATER, BUT THAT LED TO A
DIFFERENT SHUTDOWN OF SORTS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF PUERTO RICO'S
WORLD BY UNION PROTESTS, AND ONE
OF THOSE UNIONS SEND A LETTER TO
MIRANDA'S FATHER.
>> THE LETTER ENDED UP SAYING
THAT THERE ARE REAL PROBLEMS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF PUERTO RICO
AND WE WANT TO ADVISE THOSE
THINGS, PROTEST CAN HAPPEN
AROUND YOUR PRODUCTION.
>> LYNN
LIN MANUEL MIRANDA, HAS EVEN
MINED HIS HAMILTON SCORE FOR
PROTEST SONGS.
>> ♪♪ YOU BLOW US ALL AWAY ♪
♪ SOMEDAY, SOMEDAY ♪♪
DON'T STOP.
DON'T GIVE UP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
QUOTES SOME STUDENTS IN
PUERTO RICO LESS THAN THRILLED
THAT HAMILTON WILL BE COMING TO
CAMPUS.
ONE SAID, QUOTE, "THE ONLY
ARTIST AND PEOPLE THAT BENEFIT
FROM "HAMILTON" ARE THE ELITE
WHITE NORTH AMERICAN SETTLERS,
THE RICH BOURGEOISIE, AND THOSE
WHO ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE AND
ASPIRE TO BECOME OPPRESSORS.
AS A LATIN PERSON, HE SHOULD BE
MORE CONSCIOUS OF WHO HAMILTON
WAS REFUSED GLORIFYING A PERSON
WHO REPRESENTS OPPRESSION.
HE COULD'VE MADE A SHOW ABOUT
HARRIET TUBMAN."
IN ADDITION TO THE UNION GROUP,
STUDENTS ALSO ARE TESTING THE
PRODUCTION ON CAMPUS BUT HOW DID
MR. "NOT TAKING AWAY MY SEAN"
REACT IN THE FACE OF THE LEFTIST
THREAT THAT SADLY, HE CAME
TO THE PRESSURE AND MOVE THE
PRODUCTION TO AN ART CENTER OFF
CAMPUS.
MIRANDA GAVE INTO MOB RULE.
HE ALSO MISSED A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE WORLD PRESS
LOOKING ON, NO LESS, TO
CHALLENGE AND EDUCATE THE
ILLIBERAL FORCES UNDERMINING
FREE SPEECH ON CAMPUS.
EVEN ART THAT PRETTY MUCH
SUPPORTS THEIR AGENDA!
IF THESE COLLEGE KNOTS ARE
EMBOLDENED ENOUGH TO GO AFTER
THEIR FAVORITE SON, WHO GAVE
THEM A MILLION BUCKS TO REBUILD
A THEATER?
WORKING OTHER PERFORMERS EXPECT!
AND, LIN, WHAT WOULD HAMILTON
HAVE DONE?
>> IT WAS A OVATION LIKE NO
OTHER.
AFTER SO MUCH PAIN.
THE ULTIMATE TRIBUTE.
>> Laura: WELL, MIRANDA NEVER
LOOKED BACK.
THE WHOLE CONTROVERSY AND ENTIRE
EPISODE IN CAPITULATION WAS LOST
TO THE SWIRL OF CELEBRITY AND
GLAMOUR.
JUST THE WAY THE LEFT LIKES IT.
OH, AND SOME OF THOSE 30 PLUS
BIDDING DEMOCRATS WERE RIGHT
THERE ALONG IN THE AUDIENCE
SUNDAY NIGHT.
BUT POOR BABIES, THEY HAD TO BUY
MAKE THEIR OWN TICKETS ACCORDING
TO REPORTS.
BUT DON'T WORRY.
THEY GOT TO ATTEND AN AFTER
PARTY WITH A CAST FOR FREE.
COURTESY OF THE LATINO VICTORIES
OF THE LIBERAL PAC.
TV ELITES ALWAYS STICK TOGETHER.